thank you
foreign
you've heard all the Congressional
leaders make it clear that the false is
not an option the president has said
that the speaker has said that and we
want the American people to understand
that as well preventing default is not a
matter of debate it's basically response
the responsibility of Congress
what is Up For Debate though is the
budget
and that's what these discussions are
about two very different fiscal Visions
for our country and our economy
the president's plan invests in America
and grows the economy from the bottom up
and the middle out and it does that
while reducing the deficit by nearly
three trillion dollars over 10 years by
asking the wealthy and corporations to
pay their fair share and by slashing
wasteful spending on special interest
House Republicans proposed and passed a
very very different plan they want to
slash programs millions of hard-working
Americans count on while also protecting
tax breaks skewed to the wealthy and
corporations that will add 3.5 trillion
dollars to the debt that's where these
negotiations began
so look the president is negotiating
team are going to continue to fight for
the president's vision and for his
priorities and they're going to do that
in good faith at the end of the day
everyone understands that the only way
to move forward here is with a
bipartisan reasonable agreement on the
budget that can win support from both
sides from both Democrats and
Republicans in the house and in the
Senate
so there's no alternative to this this
is the path that we need to take and
that's what we're focused on to make
sure that we're getting things done for
the American people so before I go into
questions I just want to say a couple of
words about George Floyd
today three years after the murder of
George Floyd President Biden paid
tribute to George Floyd his family and
Advocates who have fought tirelessly for
reforming accountability measures this
morning the President also vetoed a
congressional republican-led
disapproval resolution that would have
nullified crucial police reforms many
enacted in the District of Columbia on
an emergency basis in 2020 after George
Floyd's murder such as Banning
chokeholds said setting important
restrictions on use of force and deadly
force improving access to body worn
camera recordings and requiring officer
training on de-escalation and use of
force the president has repeatedly said
we have an obligation to make sure that
all people all Americans are safe and
that Public Safety depends on public
Trust
it is a core policy of this
Administration to provide law
enforcement the re the resources they
need for Effective accountability
community policing and that's why last
year the president signed an executive
order on advancing effective
accountability accountable police
policing and criminal justice practices
to enhance public trust Public Safety
which requires federal law enforcement
agencies to do the following ban choke
holds restrict no knock warrants mandate
the use of body worn cameras Implement
stronger use of force policies provide
de-escalation training submit use of
forced data to the FBI's use of force
data collection submit officer
misconduct records into a new National
Database and restrict the transfer of
military equipment to local enforcement
agencies the Administration has made
significant progress implementing these
goals as detailed in a White House fact
sheet issued just this morning but we
know that achieving comprehensive and
Lasting change at the state and local
levels requires Congress to act so today
once again President Biden is urging
Congress to pass meaningful reform
legislation including the George Floyd
Justice and policing act it is it is up
to Congress to send this to his desk and
once they do he will sign this law
okay with that Josh good to see you my
friend good to see you okay how are you
doing on the jet line
a little better a little bit how are you
doing uh I could be doing better
um
so so two questions yeah two subjects uh
first given the status of the debt limit
talks that you just outlined Congress
and President Biden both be in DC this
weekend look and I've got this question
uh I can only speak for the president I
can't speak for uh the speaker and how
he pers he he chooses to move forward
with Congress what I can say is that the
president could could deal with this
issue anywhere he is and so I'll just
leave it as that
um secondly the Supreme Court said in a
ruling today that Wetlands can only be
regulated under the Clean Water Act if
they have a boat continuous surface
connection to a larger regulated of
body's water does the White House injury
with this view so a couple of things I
know that this decision uh was clearly
made as you just laid out today so look
the way that we see it it aims to the
Court's decision today aims to take our
country backwards it will jeopardize the
sources of clean and drinking water for
Farmers businesses and millions of
Americans uh look the the Clean Water
Act is the reason why America's Lakes
today are uh swimmable why we can fish
in our streams and rivers and why safe
drinking water comes out of our of our
Taps so it was uh passed as we all know
by by bipartisan majority in Congress
back in 1972 and has since been used by
Republican and Democratic
administrations alike to protect our
nation's land in water water so our
legal team as you can imagine as you all
know is is carefully reviewing the
decision and we'll have more to say on
this soon but know this that President
Biden will use every legal Authority
available to him to ensure Americans in
every state have clean water and and so
clean water and it not just clean but
also certainly safe to drink so that is
going to be our priority I have a couple
questions on the debt ceiling we're now
just seven days out from the treasury
government
so our message
and will and has been very clear and as
that we are standing this is a president
that's standing up against what
Republicans themselves are saying is a
hostage taking and threatening a default
that would cause a recession costs about
eight costs up to eight million jobs and
increase costs for all Americans that's
what the president is fighting for
that's what we want to make sure
Americans know this is what we're been
trying to do these past couple of weeks
and we're fighting against Republicans
extreme devastating proposals that would
slash as you've heard me say Law
Enforcement Education food assistance
all of these things are critical to
American families who are just trying to
make ends meet so what the people should
know what the American people should
know that we are not taking any hostages
here the fault is not an option we want
to reduce the deficit which is why the
president put uh put made sure to make
that a priority in his March 9th budget
that he released for fiscal year 2024
which is decreasing the the debt the
deficit by an extra three trillion
dollars on top of what he has been able
to do 1.7 trillion dollars in the first
two years again a historic number and we
are negotiating with Republicans in good
faith and we as as I mentioned yesterday
and as the president mentioned on Sunday
we offered an additional
cut to the spending of one trillion
dollars on top of the 3 trillion that we
mentioned in our budget the president's
Budget on March not March 9th and on top
of what we've been able to do the the
first two years so that's our Focus
we're fighting for the American people
and that's what we're going to continue
to do when Americans here default is not
an option can they also hear a guarantee
from the White House that the government
will be able to deliver their deposits
next we're going to do everything that
we can to make sure that default is
indeed not an option and here's not just
from us we heard from all four leaders
in this past and this week from speaker
McCarthy as well as well as the
president say that default is not an
option so that's what we're moving
towards
has the president spoken with speaker
McCarthy since their meeting on Tuesday
I don't have a call to preview for you
at this time okay why why haven't they
talked the president is giving
negotiators the space
and uh the time to negotiate we see
their conversation as being productive I
can let you know and some of you may
already know this they met virtually the
negotiators on both sides met virtually
at 11 30 this morning and we see this as
a productive uh conversation and it's
moving forward in in hopefully in the
path where we would see a bipartisan
reasonable budget negotiation as these
negotiations have progressed there have
been some concerns from Progressive
lawmakers about what the White House
might be willing to give today
Congressman Jamal Bowman told my
colleague Raju that we don't negotiate
with terrorists globally why are we
going to negotiate with the economic
terrorists here that are the Republican
party and he said he's very concerned
that the president will give in to
Republican demands for spending cuts so
what kind of assurances can you provide
Congressman Bowman perhaps Democrats
across the country who are concerned
that this White House is going to allow
spending cuts not just stories here's
the thing the president is fighting to
protect clean energy manufacturing he's
fighting to protect Health Care he's
fighting to protect student debt relief
and to lower costs for prescription
drugs and save the government money that
is what the president is fighting for
that's what you saw in his March 9th
budget and that's what he's going to
continue to do he's fighting against
proposal that take away health care and
increasingly put people in poverty
American people in poverty and so you
saw this well the president said this on
Sunday he's not going to agree on a deal
that that protects a 30 billion dollar
tax break for Big Oil which may which uh
which made 200 billion dollars last year
while putting health care for 21 million
people 21 million Americans ask at risk
by uh going after Medicaid he's not
going to agree to a deal that protects
200 billion dollars in subsidies for big
Pharma you heard us say that and cuts
over a hundred thousand School teachers
and assistants and 30 000 Law
Enforcement Officers we've been very
clear about that and so we have laid out
what the president is fighting for and
he's going to continue to do that what
I'm not hearing here though is that your
rule you're you're not you're not ruling
out cutting spending Beyond this current
fiscal year what I'm saying what I've
said and I've been very clear we're just
not going to read out uh and not I'm not
going to negotiate from here I'm not
going to read out conversations that we
have from here what I can say is lay out
what the president said on Sunday who's
been very clear what he's fighting for
health care right clean energy
manufacturing he's helped he's he's
fighting for to make sure that a student
debt relief exists all of those things
are really key to what the president is
fighting for he is not for uh taking
away people's Health Care talking about
21 million people he's not for that and
May and pushing people into poverty no
he's not for that either so I'm not
going to get into specifics of the
negotiation but that's what the
president has been very clear on is the
president confident that he can deliver
the necessary Democratic votes on any
deal that he agrees to with speaker
McArdle so look a little bit about that
uh look I'm not going to get uh to speak
to uh exact number right that's not
something I'm going to do from here but
the president and the speaker have said
the The Only Way Forward is to have a
bipartisan reasonable budget agreement
that's going to need both Democrats and
Republicans in the house and in the
Senate and if you look at votes votes
during the Trump Administration 70 to
200 house Democrats voted to prevent
default each time it came up during
Donald Trump's uh tenure as president
and of course the Senate requires 60
votes as we all know which will which
will be necessary which will of course
mean that you need a bipartisan vote in
the Senate so we know this vote will
require again Democrats and Republican
votes so which means that when you
negotiate when these negotiations happen
both sides have to understand that
neither side is going to get everything
that they want and so that's what we're
working towards that's what you've been
seeing from the negotiation team
scheduling then I'll come back down
Green uh secretary treasury secretary
Janet Yellen yesterday said she would be
soon providing a more precise X date for
default have you has the White House
gotten any any indication from Treasure
of what that date could be no we have
not it's something for uh that's
something for the treasury Department
too is the White House operating under
the assumption that a deal needs to be
approved by June 1st what I can really
say about that is I can you know
guess before you know send you to refer
you to secretary Yellen who has said
that it would be as early as June 1st
and uh and today said and then recently
said uh it would almost certainly be
June 1st I could just only for it refer
you to what she has said uh previously
most recently I think earlier this week
she has been pretty much communicating
with all of you what the X date is to
the American people and that's all I can
really share with you deal needs to be
approved by June 1st well we she has
said the likely the likely X date is
June 1st and so we are trying to make
sure that we get we get the budget
negotiation done as soon as possible so
that we can make sure that we avoid the
fall again but default is not negotiable
it is should be done without conditions
but of course we are working towards
this budget negotiation
thanks Cory um rep Kevin Hearn who leads
the largest Republican caucus told
Reuters earlier today that he believed a
deal to raise the debt ceiling was
likely uh by Friday afternoon can you
comment on I don't have a timeline for
you we want this to be done as soon as
possible that's why the negotiators have
been working around the clock 24 hours
practically to get this done I just
mentioned they met at 11 30 virtually
and of course this is a priority and we
certainly see the urgency of getting
this done as soon as possible but as it
relates to the debt limit this this can
be done as Shalonda young said at this
Podium the OMB director she said you can
write this up in five minutes and get
this done you can write the piece of
legislation in minutes and get that done
and make sure that the Congress does to
its constitutional Duty it's not a hard
thing to do can you abuse give us a
sense of whether negotiators are getting
close I know they met this well I said
they've been it's been productive so
clearly that means there continues to be
a path forward I not going to get ahead
of this I'm not going to get ahead of
the the negotiation process but as I've
said many times they are productive they
continue to talk negotiation you need to
have a conversation and that's
continuing and I think that's an
important uh important step forward that
we're seeing
supporting showing that both sides are
edging close to a deal with but he's
just a 70 billion dollars apart on
discretionary standard I'm just not
happy I'm not going to get into details
from here and I have a quick one on
Russia if Russia has moved ahead on
Thursday with a plan to deploy a
tactical nuclear weapons in Belarus um
this is the first such deployment since
uh since 1991 do you think does the
White House have a common company so
look we've seen the reports of Russia
Belarus Arrangement and will continue to
monitor uh certainly the implications
here we have not seen any reason to
adjust our own nuclear posture you've
heard us say that before nor any
indications of Russia is preparing to
use nuclear weapons for Belarus speaking
uh to that particular issue this is yet
another example of making irresponsible
and provocative choices so we remain
committed to Collective defense of the
NATO alliance and I'll just leave it
there
when you say that default is not an
option is that equal to saying to
guaranteeing that there will be a deal
or is there a viable Plan B
so what I can say is there is no they're
really this is the only option that we
have is for Congress to do its job for
Congress to uh deal with the debt limit
that's the only option in front of us
that is the best option for the American
people that's the best way to make sure
that our economy uh is not doesn't get
turned on its head that we don't get a
situation where we leave we potentially
lose up to eight million jobs or
devastate retirement accounts that is
not an option so we're being consistent
here we've been saying that they need to
do their job it is their constitutional
duties been done 78 times since 1960
that's what we're saying as it relates
to the budget negotiation those are
continuing we want to make sure that
gets done as soon as possible as well it
is important for the American people to
see what we value and what we see in a
bipartisan way that we're going to
present to the American people clearly
also to Congress so that it can get both
Democrat and Republican votes
a deal there is no plan B
I can say is the only option right now
is for the for Congress to do their jobs
without conditions that is the way that
we need to move forward as it relates to
the debt limit
when we're on something the president
said during his news conference he
suggested that Mega Republicans may use
default for political gain
does he include Kevin McCarthy in that
so look we are working in good faith
with Kevin McCarthy right now and with
his team and the hope is that we
continue that continues right the good
faith uh the good faith conversations to
deal with the budget to deal with uh the
budget negotiations so that is something
that I would say as it relates you heard
me talk about specifically about some
what some House Republicans were saying
yesterday and what we wanted to make
sure is that we laid out the facts and
that was coming from the house Freedom
caucus and they were you've heard them
argue against preventing default and
against negotiating for a bipartisan
budget agreement in violation that is
actually in violation of what the
speaker has said he wanted and what the
speaker has said he's committed to so
we're going to flag that for all of you
we're going to flag that for the
American people but the speaker was very
clear last week he said actually this
week he said that when it comes to
default it's off the table
um
personal a housekeeping question it's
been a few days since we've heard from
the president directly on the state of
negotiations I'm wondering if we might
hear from him either in the Rose Garden
here shortly or later today to offer an
update on me I would say stay tuned my
friend stay tuned consider that um to
follow up on ouija's last question
the former president is in the area he
was spotted Which Way former president
Trump okay there's a few formers so you
have to be clear he was spotted across
the river at the liftgoff tournament
that's coming up this weekend here in
the area and a reporter from The New
York Times covering the tournament spoke
with him and the former president showed
in fact that he had recently spoken with
speaker McCarthy said that they had a
little quick talk and he predicted that
the dead talks were going to be getting
a deal would be harder than people were
expecting I wonder if the White House is
a reaction to the fact that the current
Speaker is speaking to the former
president at the time his team is
talking to her president the speaker is
allowed to speak to whoever he chooses
and wants to speak to so I'm not going
to certainly dive into that or step in
step on that what I can speak to is what
the speaker has said very publicly
himself just this week that default is
off the table We are continuing to have
productive conversations negotiations
continue again I just mentioned how the
the two teams met this morning virtually
11 30. that is a good sign that is a
good sign that those talks are certainly
continuing and look we have said we
think there's a path forward there's a
path forward to a bipartisan uh
reasonable budget agreement and uh and
as long as both sides understand that no
one is going to get everything that it
wants then we can get there we can get
there this is about the American people
this is about American families making
sure that we are meeting their needs and
that that should be the focus that's not
an indication of bad faith if the
speakers
I mean I can't I don't know what the
speaker said to uh the former president
I cannot speak to that you would have to
speak ask the speaker directly what I
can speak to is what we heard from
direct from the speaker directly and
with his teams with his team is doing it
is we're continuing to have these good
faith conversations that's what's
important the negotiations continue and
so I think that's what's important here
I cannot speak to a conversation I hear
say conversation that is occurring that
occurred I just can't speak to that
another topic as I was following Twitter
last night during the announcement of
Rhonda Sanchez's candidacy it appeared
that there were some members of the
president's team who were doing the same
and maybe enjoying a little bit of the
glitches that appear to be happening I
wonder if you had a reaction to that but
also to the fact that Elon Musk is
offering this platform uh to a you know
potential leading Republican candidate
for the office with the president
consider doing the same on that same but
so look um I'm not going to speak to
Twitter and their operation as a private
company just not going to do that from
here as you know we follow the law here
this is an Administration that cares
about the law and about not certainly
not using taxpayer money to campaign
from here that is something that we've
been pretty consistent and we've also
you know I just got questions from your
colleagues about the president's
policies and his agenda and how he sees
moving forward especially on the economy
me and so honestly we just haven't had
the time to take in any rapid
unscheduled assemblies if you will and
so I'll just leave it that I think I'll
just add really you know the presence
presence uh focus is on middle class
Americans it's on working Americans
making sure that we deliver an economy
that works for them that doesn't leave
them behind that builds an economy from
the bottom up middle out that's our
Focus
okay right now
oh it's early but if it's possible to
keep going okay okay
okay wow that's good
thanks Irene um do you worry that the
spending cuts might affect Ukraine
assistance in the long run
so as you've heard us say many times
before the president has been clear that
it will is going to continue to work
with our allies and partners to support
Ukraine as long as it takes that is a
commitment that we have to the Ukrainian
people you've heard that from the
president you've heard that from my NSC
colleagues and you certainly have heard
that from me so we have been gratified
and pleased to see the bipartisanship uh
the bipartisan support for Ukraine uh
Ukraine from members of both parties in
both the house and the Senate and so uh
and we expect that to continue and I'll
leave it there for for uh for as it
relates to the aid sure on Russia the
Wagner group said after the uh
cleared basically inviting the Russian
army to take over and they say if they
don't then we are bigger than the
Russian army I know that the White House
declared him a terrorist and a criminal
group but this is anything more that you
can do to fulfill the ambulance
so look I'm Gonna Leave it to uh to
others to analyze Mr pagosian's colorful
colorful statements that he made
yesterday so I'll leave it to others
certainly not going to step into that
but I'll just say this that when it
comes to the United States and our
commitment to holding those responsible
for perpetrating uh Russia's war against
Ukraine to account that's what we're
going to do we've been very clear about
that as well that includes the Wagner
group against which we have taken
specific actions including through sex
sanctions and by designating them as a
trans transnational criminal
organization a result of their
destabilizing action and criminal
activity and human rights abuses in
Ukraine and around the world these
designations and other actions have
Frozen the Wagner group's assets in the
U.S and prohibited Americans from
providing
providing food and and funds I'm sorry
goods and services to the group so we'll
continue to take action and to hold them
into account and that has been our
commitment for the past several months
okay okay
one time doing together
right now
okay six more okay why don't does the
pool gather and I'll take I'll take a
couple more
come on uh go ahead Garrett thank you
okay well we'll do the best that we can
go ahead Garrett on General Brown's
appointment uh as chairman of the Joint
Chiefs uh obviously if he's confirmed he
will become only the second
African-American to serve in this role
and he would also make history with
secretary Austin for the first time in
history the first top two uh Pentagon
positions being occupied by
African-Americans what significance of
this whole uh for this white house so
look let me just first say uh and the
president's going to speak to this and
in uh in just a few moments so certainly
I'm sure you'll you'll take his his um
his response to this important
appointment but I want to recognize
chairman Millie's lifetime of service to
our country the president is immensely
grateful to Chairman Millie who has been
a close and trusted advisor to President
Biden over the past two and a half years
and uh for who for for who um for how he
has worked with second Terry Austin to
help our military address significant
challenges respond to new threats and
end America's longest war and strengthen
alliances and Partnerships around the
world and general Brown the president
knows that he will benefit from a leader
with a wealth of military experience
shaped in both peace peace time and War
just like he has from chairman Millie as
well as someone who understands the
Strategic challenges
that that lies ahead that we face that
the U.S faces around the world but who
also will ably represent the men and
women of our Armed Forces as well as
their as their families and so look he
is immensely talented he's it has been
amazing to uh to watch this process he's
clearly going to make history he's
already made history as our nation's
first black Service Chief and he has
been an important voice helping make our
Armed Forces more inclusive including
through the video he recorded three
years ago just after the murder of
George Floyd that went viral and struck
a chord with Americans across the street
across I'm sorry across the country so
clearly this is important uh we are the
president is proud to uh to nominate him
I'm going to let the president speak
more about the importance of uh his
historical choice
on the on the George Floyd anniversary
has the White House been in touch with
the boy family and maybe updating them
on these uh on the implementation of the
EO no it's a good question we just don't
have any calls to to preview as you know
the president has spoken and met with
the family multiple times and they were
they were here recently at the White
House just last year go ahead yeah
thanks uh so Fitch a credit rating
agency has already put the US in a
credit negative watch that's one Domino
that needs to fall before downgrade
um the president's going to Camp David
this weekend going to Delaware can you
describe the sense of urgency that the
president feels to get a deal done
there's almost there's all there's
always been urgency we've called this
out over and over again how urgent it is
to get this done it is just one more
piece of evidence if you will so we've
been laying out again for months and
months how catastrophic this could be if
Congress didn't do its job and and deal
with the debt limit as it's
constitutional for them to be doing that
includes impacts to the credit rating of
the United States collection of our full
faith and credit and also this
underscores the need for Swift
bipartisan action by Congress to prevent
default this is has to be done in a
bipartisan way this has been done 78
times since 1960. we have been calling
out the urgency of getting the debt
limit done for Congress to get the debt
limit done for weeks now for months and
so this is just another piece of
evidence that defaults should not be an
option it is not an option all the
leaders who have met the Congressional
leaders who have met what the president
has said default is off the table so
even if a deal is done today the process
could still take us into the middle of
June to get it to the president's desk
and to sign it so is there a message
then to companies people about that that
could be past the X date so look as I've
said what the our message to the
president from the president to the
American people is that we are fighting
we are fighting to make sure that we
protect American families we're fighting
to make sure that uh that you know we're
continuing to build a economy from the
bottom-up middle out this is what we are
fighting for this is what the president
is fighting for we're going to continue
to tell and continue to say what we've
been saying for lunch which is Congress
needs to get this done it needs to be
done in a bipartisan way it's been done
again 78 times since 1960. so this is an
important important uh clearly
constitutional Duty that Congressman I
can guarantee that any deal will be
fast-tracked
we've already said how urgent this is
we've been very clear about how urgent
it is to deal with the debt limit again
this is another piece of evidence that
we are seeing uh and that lays that out
that lays out that default is not an
option all right thank you thanks guys
thank you